the fourth cumin attach there's two ways
you can either
both soften together
it's a little bit like the ken keema
souvenir patch
eye open
i do go offline for this where all the
communications you don't know me
i ski in here
notice this is from the second clear
attack
don't leave it out there
bring it back in
there
so you have to go around you put weight
on
the pen like the second gimmick actually
right so the fourth
can be quite boring
as far as there's parts of the sector
or you can just do it open
up as he comes in you just dig your hips
okay
all right so you get that
and then you're back to shimmer
secondary apache
my most favorite one here is the
um
thai jitsu application
up
hey
okay
and that's that one it's very difficult
to do
because you have to mold
like a snail shell you have to mold
yup
but it needs no pressure push
no pressure
what does this remind you of
perhaps how smooth
so they start all into mingling
you know you don't realize them and then
you go what can we touch what we're
doing because this was the same as that
one and that one
hey